if you are going to try something hard
if you're putting yourself out there in
some way there are going to be times
where you screw up or you don't succeed
successful people see failure as part of
the process
most people allow their fear of failure
80% allow their fear of failure Tagle
their desire to succeed rise and shine
it's an espresso time good morning
belief nation it's evan my one word is
believe and i believe in you i believe
you have an amazing gift inside to you
that i want to see exploded on to the
world so let's start your day off right
together grab your coffee and sip on
today's message learn from failures over
to you barack obama with respect to
failure it's terrible but but but
necessary if you if you are going to try
something hard if you're putting
yourself out there in some way there are
going to be times where you screw up or
you don't succeed or there are times
where you do everything right and you
still don't succeed but that's not just
true of politics or running a
non-for-profit that's true some of you
talked about being entrepreneurial if
you're starting a clothing line that's
that's a cutthroat business it yeah I'm
sure you yeah I have every confidence I
out of it you're gonna succeed at some
point but you'll go through some
failures you know and and I think that
the most important thing and and this is
a little bit of a cliche but sometimes
clichés are true is to learn from those
failures and to have a sense of
resilience and be able to examine what
is it that I did not succeed at why
didn't I succeed and what do I need to
do better if you're focused on giving of
your
self to accomplish something then even
when you fail at a particular objective
you're still succeeding in learning
about how you can accomplish those goals
the difference between people who win
and the people who don't is how they
view failure people who aren't
successful see failure as this final
thing take failure personally see that
when they fail that it's a reflection of
themselves that because they failed at
making a youtube video it means that
they personally are failure that's what
unsuccessful people do successful people
see failure as part of the process like
you will fail your way to victory the
most successful people in the world are
the people who failed the most because
they tried the most and they also win
the most I don't think we can ever get a
week on this channel without talking
about failure and it's not so much the
successful people who really care about
talking about it it's everybody else
it's all the people who want to be
successful it's all the people who have
the ambition but never seem to get there
because they have the wrong mindset
around failure so they're asking how do
you deal with failure how do you deal
with failure and inevitably it's the
same form of an answer that failures
part of the process that failure is
normal if failure is natural that you
have to fail and so I really encourage
you to want to shift that mindset that
you have around what a failure looks
like what are you so afraid of
and often it's not just you failing it's
failing in front of somebody else
failing in front of your friends failing
in front of the community failing in
front of your parents failing in front
of the people around you you're worried
about the judgement of them you could
fail about yourself if nobody sees it
that's okay right but your feeling in
front of somebody else that's when you
start to feel really bad and that fear
of failing in front of somebody else
prevents you from taking the action that
you need to take and so how do you get
over it well one what do you care so
much about these people who are judging
you like have they done what you're
trying to do that their opinions really
mean something and if they're gonna
judge you for making a mistake
why do you want to be around that person
why do you care so much about their
thoughts there's a great Quincy Jones
line where he said not one ounce of my
self-worth comes from your acceptance of
me if you've built up yourself worth
based on what other people think about
you you're always gonna lose
especially from people who are not out
winning if your self-worth comes from
your group of friends and nobody's off
doing big things and every time you try
to take a shot and you fail you're
worried that they're going to laugh at
you then guess what you're gonna stay
with that group of friends forever
that's your life that's who you're
always gonna be you're never going to
escape your circle because you're too
afraid of the judgment so how do you
break free the best way that I know how
is to change your environment if you
want to be confident the best way to do
it is surround yourself with confident
people if you want to learn to accept
failure and change your mindset around
it the best way to do it is be around
successful people who have a different
mindset around failure because you could
read a book on the 10 ways to overcome
failure and that may help you for that
day but it's the consistent exposure to
that idea this is why I created my
channel this is why we talk about it
every week my hope is that whether it's
through a night's rest or through a top
10 the through or mentor me eventually
you'll get the message and I created the
channel for myself to be around these
really successful people because the
people around me are great they're
fantastic and loving but nobody's really
pushing me to do more right everybody in
my life is saying evident you're doing
such a great job congratulations you had
a million subscribers it's all awesome
and I appreciate that but who's saying
Evan you did you're doing ok but you
kind of suck like you should be doing
this way out here right the kick forward
and so I get that from the videos I get
that because I'm hanging around Steve
Jobs and elem us and Oprah Winfrey every
single day and so if you want to change
that perspective anything that you want
to change right this does negative
pattern then surround yourself and
create an environment that is the
opposite the more you watch these videos
or at least videos around failure if
that's a daily practice for you you
can't help but start to think like them
if you are watching Ilan muscle videos
or Denzel Washington videos on a daily
basis I guarantee you you'll start to
think behave and act like Elon Musk and
Denzel Washington if all you do is hang
around your friends
then I guarantee you're gonna think like
your friends thing and so most people
don't design their environment with any
degree of consciousness stop waking up
like it's an accident
have some purpose design your routine
create an environment that supports you
and change that mindset if you have
around failure now I've got a really
important bonus clip for you but before
getting to it my question the day for
you is what does failure mean to you how
would you define it I'm really curious
to see what your answers are leaving the
comments below thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of an espresso and enjoy the bonus
I think that the people that are on that
are discovering how to unleash their
greatness are people who have the mental
resiliency and the courage to face
failure if you will fail your way to
greatness that most people allow their
fear of failure
80% allow their fear of failure talk--we
their desire to succeed when you're
willing to fail again and again and
again when you make up your mind to
become unstoppable when you make up your
mind to become a no matter what person
then that will then give birth to a part
of yourself that you don't know right
now so what you learn out of failure in
there a lot of failures like I can't go
a day without feeling something but it's
just like what you what you take from
you and like that's I think where I
thrive is just like okay I'm not gonna
make that mistake that same way again
how can I use that
yes when you think about your risk
tolerance for failure how far are you
willing to fail well I mean
unfortunately unfortunately I felt quite
a bit you know but I understand that's
actually part of the process of
succeeding I'm not one I really believe
in failure I believe you have setbacks
and you know you have to learn from
those you have to learn what are those
landmines that can be avoided the next
time what are those pitfalls you have to
learn from that stuff so you know
welcome those things it's a part of life
but are you prepared to like really fail
it's something totally new like what if
you're just VC Dunamis you VC yeah you
know and then I work at it and then I'm
not as easy the next yeah you know
whenever it happens yeah listen I my
first year in league on national TV 18
years old got shot five straight air
balls in the playoffs in front of
millions of people yeah I think my time
is pretty high raise your standard Apple
cool its core values
man not one drop of myself work depends
on your that's something sue me I don't
ever give up I'd have to be dead or
completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten Rose a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual Clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details